sir now you have a look at this right
come back to your super notation what
this is telling you it is when you
expand this whole thing right and I'm
going to know just about the X to the
two ends in there okay when you expand
this whole thing you have to add up a
bunch of those okay there are gonna be
there's gonna be this one and then the
next one and then the next one and so on
so I want you to have a look in this
series right
can you see for K equals zero right this
is the first one I have to do all of
them okay for K equals zero
I'm going to get down on all these terms
but I'm really interested in one of them
and you have to look carefully it's not
obvious right away which one it is okay
which one of them will have an X to the
2n in the term look when k equal 0 for K
equals 0 right in this series let me let
me actually start to read this off so
you write this is going to be 2 NC 0
times 2 to the 2n minus 0 times X to the
2n mother's Europe oh wait I got it okay
I'm gonna get to the K term eventually
this term for K equals 0 this term here
will have an extra 2 in in it you see
that okay I'm gonna write that down a
second okay before I do I want to think
logically before I have am i working
there well what happens for the next one
for K equals 1 okay now where will the X
to the 2n term be and I can tell you
right now it's not gonna be this term is
it right this will not have a power of X
to the 2n when I put in K equals 1 is
that ah my power will be something else
I don't know what'll be but it won't be
X into it right in fact you need this
one do you see that when I put K plus 1
into this whole thing I have a whole
bunch of terms but only one I'm
interested in is that one because K
equals 1 there will leave me just that
extra 2 it does that make sense okay so
for each value of K I need to pick out
which one of the terms I've want okay so
therefore to try and borrow us down
all right I'm going to
I'm not gonna drill mines for it by
basically I'm gonna draw up some tables
and value C so here's what I'm gonna
have underneath that I just know I'm not
gonna have enough space on the
right-hand side
okay what I want to compare is a value
of K and then I want to compare to the
coefficients of X to the two and that I
get out of this thing okay take a breath
for K equals zero remember what I'm
doing is this right because I'm looking
for the coefficient next to it in this
cuz that would give them the community
coefficient of exit 2n in this which I
happen to know is that house of luncheon
cooking okay so therefore I have to
actually have this whole thing in there
right so for K equals zero the first
thing that I write down is what's in the
same notation it's two nc0 it's it's
from there do you see that in fact I'm
gonna underline it with the same color
so that you get raises coming from that
guy there you piece here okay and then I
have to work out this thing and you guys
told me for K equals zero this is the
term that I care about the rest of them
are irrelevant
okay so I'm going to write down the bits
of that they correspond to K equals zero
so I'm gonna have this have a look to n
minus k c0 2 to the 2n minus 0 you see
where I got that from okay let me
underlined it there it is and I don't
need to write that there's X to the 2n
minus 0 there because I'm just talking
about the coefficient right so I've
already kind of thought that it's gonna
have an extra to it okay I've got one of
them let's write down the next one okay
so k equals 1 again I return to the
Sigma notation and there's a 2 and C
okay in there so I've got 2 and C okay
okay that comes from the green bit again
and then I've got to deal with this guy
and you told me okay then the next
number along the next term alone I
should say that's gonna give me that
excellent two in for K equals 1 okay
so I'm gonna say all right now I'm going
live to n minus 1 right C 1 to the power
of 2 to the 2 and okay careful there's a
new power there isn't there this was
part of our pattern that changed as we
went along the power is no longer to the
to n minus K the power 2 is 2 to the 2 n
minus 2 minus 1 minus 1 yeah someone
write that down
in fact I'm even gonna write minus 1
minus 1 okay I'll simplify all this out
in the video I'm going to do one more
and then I can get to the general terms
so ok equals to come back to the Sigma
notation it's got this green bit here
and then I get to the red part the big
expansion that they used an identity for
2 n minus 2 C 2 okay do you see why I
had to write down that next one right
because I'm going to talk about it now
this 4 K goes to this potatoes to do you
see this is the term I'm interested in
now because the two days are two down
will cancel
yeah so have a look at what's happening
here what's the power of 2 it's 2 n
minus 2 minus 2 2 n minus 2 dot dot dot
now think where's this thing going to
end we're making it in this thing
pays to anyone when which K are we
talking about okay so what I've written
here is having a look at yes that should
be nice okay all right I want you to
look carefully at this for a second have
a look at it well they have n sorry what
value of K would make sense to be the
last thing and this isn't a lot not
immediately obvious okay where would you
go up to four here for this to be
meaningful okay now let me give you an
example something which seems like what
makes sense but actually doesn't okay
think about what would happen for K
equals two now just think about it for a
second cake was - it seems like a
reasonable thing to go for because like
you've got powers of 2 n I think that
should be my last term all right I think
but if you put two men in - wherever you
see K what happens well what happened to
you what's this thing gonna be you don't
have to go any further that this is
gonna be what choose not there
something's gone wrong here right this
is not right this shouldn't go all the
way up to 0 C 0 that's nonsensical
where's the last set what's usually the
last term on the end of Pascal's
triangle on any row it should be NCM
right or - Nancy - M or whatever these
two things should be the same right
I think cake was N is the most suited to
end on okay so I'm going to write this
down the nth term
okay all that one is a general term
right so the general term I can write
down with and have a think about where
where this be where is it where this
thing actually ends right have a look
see if I'm into 0 see how it ends at
zero have a look at what power you'd
have to get up to to make that zero
right
oh do you see I'm gonna pretty and
you'll see what I get out of this and
when I do and I'm gonna get okay look
what does this bit become - n n - M - M
+ 2 - that so you guys - 8 - k 2 n minus
K minus 1 these are dropping down by
careful careful
have a look they're dropping down by -
right look do you see my pattern look at
my pattern this is why I had I needed
this pattern so desperately right and
went from two ends of 2 and minus 2 2
and minus 4 because look see we're doing
two things right this thing is going up
one at a time but so is this they're
both going up one at a time which means
in the end you go two at a time
does that make sense see you've gone to
N two months to two n minus 4 this is to
the 2n minus minus n minus n which is
two men that make sense
that's the power of X you see remember
remember again which power of X to Y
once I want X to the 2n the value of K
that will give me X to the 2n here right
here is for integrity 2n I want that to
be M okay so do you see now my argument
for why my last value is kate was in do
you see where he is the tricky thing the
row of Pascal's triangle that you're on
depends on the value of okay right it
depends on the value okay so you're
actually looking at different rooms you
are adding up a whole bunch of the
different roads
alright it's alright just file it away
for a second let me see if I can
complete this out and if the logic will
come together for okay so therefore
these are all of the coefficients you'll
come out the front of X to the 2n based
on this guy right but I know that they
should all be equal to this right visit
you there yeah that makes sense that's
the coefficient that I got in part 1 so
this is equal to I've got to add up all
these things now okay so I've got I've
got this guy that's the first one I'm
doing I can simplify some numbers now
2 to the 2 men plus the next one
plus the next one and once I get to my
third one then I can say all right what
about the last one okay so have a look
here you can see I'm going to get to and
to the zero but look look
are we there yet have a look finally at
the result we're trying to prove okay
because I finally have this thing which
is supposed to on the left hand side
I've got something I'm supposed to get
on the right hand side does it fit what
I want look at look at the Sigma
notation okay they've said add up from
what to what
uh-huh
another clue that I needed to end upon
in onto em okay the thing I'm adding up
there are I go from zero all the way up
to M okay that's how many of these
things I'm going to get oh okay what's
the format of this thing how does it
change as you progress from one term to
the next well the top of that NCR thing
is always to n and this just goes 0 1 to
M right so that's going to be okay they
can you have a look at these guys all
right the top values in the second NCR
notation the top values keep on changing
don't they right it's 2 n take away 0 2
and take away 1 2 and take away 2 it's 2
n take away whatever your particular
value is right now and then you also
choose that particular bone and then
lastly your power of 2 2 ^ ok
the two men always states in 2n 2 and
minus 2 2 n minus 4 this is 2 n take
away their multiples of 2 depending on
whichever multiple you are on right now